welcome to this video i'm playing p for
sure Pusha okay um that would mean the
swing by joan okay no particular
information in them oops Scott let's
close that um what am I going to do
something else something that I don't
play that often maybe the maybe like
that supply the electrons defense
something different for I get 93 I know
okay mmm this is an unconventional
approach it's quite funny i I've played
this opening um sometimes and in
tournament chess and I've gotten Knight
c3 and I think two games actually and
won them both what now d 6 or d5 in
those games are played d phi phi so
remember that d 6 is also quite yeah it
also makes some sense let's attack that
pawn down if he decides to take on d6
after seat XD 6i got to Center pawns
against no center pole even Queen the
sexes is not terribly bad
yeah but ok doesn't doesn't really look
very natural to prepare to trade Queens
so early on he also yes Bishop d3 after
26 this seems logical and capturing
towards the center it's funny that if I
Teague with the if I would have taken
with the eeprom and he plays Knight f3
this is actually this is identical to
the Petrov right I would have taken away
the opponent across 93 that's exactly a
petrol of defense that's weird hmm what
do we are transposition hmm ok let's
develop so I'm setting my hopes on the
fact that my pawn structure is a little
bit better he has this double porn but
it's not a huge deal as it is quite
often a double pawn is very often um
yeah believed to be a weakness by less
experienced players while in fact it is
not really a weakness like here it's not
clear that this is a problem at all
Bishop f4 hmm that looks bit weird yeah
come on my Nigel why not grab space
originally I wanted to go g6 and Bishop
g7 but if he told if he insists then I'm
going to just grab space why not Bishop
g3 looks normal
I'm Bishop e3 feels a little bit like em
and loss of tempo Wow Bishop d3 at least
them tries to make some sense of Bishop
f4 even though it's not clear that this
Bishop is any good on g3 even f5 as a
move that looks a little bit suspicious
it's not bad though not a bad move I
have a g5 is just the totally totally
logical move young taking a big center
it's quite ironic i apply the elegance
defense to give wide the center and then
a Tekkit and sit in that game after
eight moves I've got the big center and
white tries to attack it this is really
funny ok so we five is hanging and it's
hanging for real there is no um no
tricks that would help me there ok let's
go I've six or anything else now f6 I
have to cover that next moves are Bishop
d7 Bishop e6 castling and black enjoys
the center very nicely
that looks ambitious here you are really
known castling long one problem is if I
go hmm think about this for a moment he
also can't take on d5 in some position
so if I go like Queen B 60 can take 25
this is not really great they move that
I think it's interesting is I mean we
should be six is totally normal but then
if he cancels long I have Queen 85 and
this is interesting attacking a two and
attacking of this bishop and this means
that he has to do something that he
doesn't want to do form with the quite
some certain team even a three years a
very decent move now now that I like
that the bishop belongs on e6 anyway
covering d5 and ya ready for Bishop f7
the check comes or whatever just the
place for this piece not nowhere else
and if you really if he goes long then
Queen a five and this is good for me I
guess can you go with Luke takes d5 then
and sacrificing stuff no just 92 here
ya mean developing some things it's not
a bad idea is Queen B 6 a move now or
will be six attacking that Bishop I
think I can play this is not a bad idea
he has to weaken or take on c6 I mean he
has to play like a 4-1 and echo a six
and then he has to take or I mean Bishop
d3 I even have a phone i'm winning a
piece so he cannot really retreat the
bishop yeah nighy almost has to take on
c6
don't really see how he avoids it either
now after eight sacks myself am okay
yeah BTW existe the obvious move is
Queen takes worth considering probably
not yeah now if he castles burberry I
don't take be too even though that might
be possible I don't need to is this is a
case where okay he protected this but I
wanted to say this is a case where I
don't need to wear pawns because I
already essentially have a material
advantage because of the bishop pea the
bishop pair advantages the same thing as
having extra material it's a permanent
advantage so I don't need to worry about
grabbing some porn set up somewhat
questionable I just have to continue
with normal moves and trying to convert
that advantage is Bishop 1g3 is also
really really in active at the moment
even a move like gt5 if it's not totally
of the charts just grabbing even more
space and preventing any f4 or whatever
the only thing that I really have to
worry about I mean probably not the only
thing but one thing is that the e6
Bishop is unprotected so in case of
castling rookie one there is night f for
an ID for those kind of ideas it's
important to at any moment trying to be
at least trying to be aware of what is
not quite right with your position
unprotected pieces liabilities they are
tricks with with checks this kind of the
things I'm not quite right and this is
something that is on my radar that the
c6 bishop might be a liability in terms
of check
this Queen age five but I have g6 and
Bishop f7 Bishop f7 is a benefit of
having the bishop on e6 it looks nice he
also cannot really attack that Center c4
gets taken and this really yeah didn't
make any sense and yeah I'm canceling
preparing a for that looks really
outlandish I mean it takes a long way
I'm moving the Queen the King and then
f1 this is what the Queen will be six is
also well placed on the other hand of
course you can ask the question how
exactly is black going to on gac convert
they send this noise pollution that's
really a good question
quite often them the standard procedure
is just gaining more space which is
often somehow it directly related to the
bishop am here it's not just the bishop
else in my big Center that is a
fantastic Center ideas like a 5 + c 5 +
d 4 come to mind just just grabbing
grabbing space quite often however the
solution to the question how to proceed
is some actually being answered by the
opponent because in a bad position or
bad positions often bad moves up late
and they often help you with some some
steaks
and why what I wonder is if something
like no um well it is not a really
positionally grade move but I was
running about eform because whites queen
doesn't have many squares but wow wow he
really really wants to exploit this
Bishop situation Wow okay I mean I said
it's on my radar but I didn't really
believe that um that this is the
possibility now
remarkable move so okay I will take it
and then what rupee one probably and c5
Queenie too Wow King up several tweenage
live check g6 queen age seven king-8
Queen g6 king do some mom save then come
on I really ever I have to take this I
mean not going to allow the night to
come to f5 in any case so I'm grabbing
this so rookie 1c5 mc5 if he takes on d4
I have rupee eight and this is
completely completely solved so that's
not happening c5 he plays Queenie to
there's no question there no doubt them
yeah let's do it 22 I mean even if King
f7 it's not working i can take c3 and
I'm a pawn enough which isn't isn't bad
and but isn't king of seven working the
king of seven is actually threatening
something the very simple move g6 which
leaves me with an extra porn without
anything I mean extra piece without
anything happening so after King f7 he
has to check me on edge five King g8 is
a repetition that's not going to work
so g6 Queen h7 Shack king-8 Queen g6
check King d7 yeah I've got a peaceful
for what is this two pawns yeah well
that's not that's not enough that's
really not enough but it is somewhat
murky that is really the keys yeah I
just wonder because I can click on c3 I
have this this very simple solution
hmm
again let's let's have a look there and
let's let's not overlook some obvious
candidate move is there something else
that I can do come to check out I don't
think so so king of seven check on h5 g6
Queen aged 78 Queen g6 check kingi some
hmm our King is fairly safe you will
click on deform cd4 and I could rook c8
coming as well now come on come on
that's not that's not really going to
work
yeah Quinn age five star the only only
way and I'm really just threatening g6
he cannot afford a slow move now even
seat XD for I call g6 and just keep
everything I asked the local age five
some actually slightly weird that he's
not playing their move
hmm see not playing that that would be
really strange I mean you will I mean
you have to look at the checks anyway
and
I may be a bishop c7 or something but I
can will you just take that okay well
it's not so great I understand maybe
bishops is sound yes this is maybe an
IDM checking if there's some some kind
of some kind of difference with that
with that means if i take it Queenie 68
okay and we get this okay going back
it's just draw so g six and then
check yeah an easy decision for once
maybe wait I'm just adjusting may be
doubling on the e-file was interesting
hmm add that that that that might be
real problem actually ever appeared I
mean cake in d7 I have to play anyway I
guess rookie to this is this kind of
move rookie 241 hmm
better say it looks kind of tricky
rookie to rookie a truck a one Bishop d8
home mmm-hmm I don't know
yeah his name is swing liar so maybe
rookie to where he found that move
mmm what alternatives do I have roped g8
is pushing the Queen away a little bit
yeah I like the idea 23 I might have c4
irritating him
yeah looks like I'm gaining a little bit
of time with that move it was a bit
hastily played when I hope I'm not
screwing things up he goes back I was
thinking at c4 as an option even though
i'm really i'm giving up a pawn down
just for coordination issues for
coordination sake and my and the queen
is somewhat further away from my king
Bishop g4 is also moved by the way
should reform f3 there's c4 whoa wow
maybe hey it may be
Bishop g4 f-35 what we had to move c4
takes it I had stopped going to work my
king is on D cell now completely I'm
totally hitting the self-destruct button
if i do this i wonder if c4 really as a
move just returning a little bit of
stuff
just to coordinate and make sure that my
king is a bit safer if he takes on
before I mean it's not really forced to
do some okay I can also just go rupee
eight and cover cover you six in case of
Ruby one
ok I'm going to see forward that that's
something that I might regret her I
really I really know that this is very
debatable yeah probably with hindsight I
should have just taken that porn yeah I
could have just taken a pawn much
earlier 1c three instead of that piece
maybe that was better I don't know about
yeah and I really don't believe in this
piece I profile objectively but now the
practical chances are they're an
interesting idea for why does he I
exactly not trading Queens just keep
everything on what is this he's looking
at my rook there 1a8 see how it will
look T 1 maybe here's how
cannot move them Bishop only six se 7s
hanging but it's not threatening
anything in particular as far as I see
at least rocket 88 look da drop d 1 la
cuna for I was a good move
tough
rookie one is immensely awkward
so any way to defend this stuff that's
really really really annoying
you don't see it really the through
gonna hate is also very very much an
issue yeah see for I was it was tricky
Queenie force of course very strong
hmm yes I don't see a good move not at
all whoop de juanes is just very very
strong f5 look strategically very
awkward at five Queenie for live
I don't see a move whoopty a drug tier 1
what am i doing then amazing can I
somehow can has somehow 93 is still he
takes once and then please root be one
again
let's look hva dhruti one Bishop c5 is
this kind of holding let's go to page
seven King c8 planet looks really bad I
know I didn't see anything good I have
to play a move at some point all right I
really hate to have this kind of King in
the middle amp you can really lose yeah
i can very often do some because of the
practical problems they're objectively
black ass totally totally good like five
moves ago let's aim or move 20 I think
yeah I know I don't believe in this for
white but the way I play the T got
excellent compensation
it takes a bit the pond and that didn't
even consider this move which doesn't
mean that it's bad it's just I didn't
absolutely never considered it okay
Group D one was my only concern of
course now we have three points so it's
not it's not stupid at all so it should
have been let's say honor 11 on on a
list of candidates
can I go Bishop d6 trading some stuff a
d5 bishop website has got to Queen f5
and okay 56 d 5 Bishop g4 Queen h7 check
now that might not be so bad Oh still
awful that I'm that I'm in this so
Bishop d6 was what i was thinking if you
just takes Queen takes Queen B 7 check
that's also not bad
shrimp t6g form yeah yeah I really hate
this position now I should just taken
that bloody pawn that was much much
simpler without any complication just
take that pawn and probably win in my
sleep now sometimes being principled is
not the practical decision even though
that probably was better from a pure
quality point of view initially better
not this position of course and the
other the other continuation it was just
so simple you have just them just have a
simple simple good position okay so
catch rate it and now this check makes
things easy I guess queencess illness is
my move I don't really have much much
choice why not I don't think so huh
Queen B 5 Quincy six yeah if he takes it
low key one hack ok King g6 and play
going to play that end game
end game is ok I believe my pawns are
reasonably safe there are three of them
and he doesn't pick them up quickly I
don't see how I can trade probably one
pair of rooks and then see where that
leads me I'm probably better in the end
game but not entirely sure yeah I think
now he almost has to treat Jay Wow why
this Quincy six this isn't this verse
reverse version of that end game if he
now traits and TNT has to and has made
on g2 so he really has to trade now it
doesn't have Queen 85 or anything like
that it overlooks tough no my really has
to take then-rookie one Bishop f7 maybe
he wants to play then this rookie
seventh then I have can you five yeah
okay so I now rookie one looks very very
illogical
geography one what would elson and now
Bishop d7 or Bishop f7 I'm not quite
sure about it
yeah let's go Bishop d7 on its not be
too sophisticated about it what I'm
wondering is actually if he takes it if
we take everything right die gruppe a
rookie a rookie at Bishop e aid I have a
very simple plan King b5 a foregrip da
porn promote that I wonder if that is
just working or off or if what about his
pawns so we take everything right I go
King b5 he has to flick in c3 King a 4-1
move to 458 moves I take eight moves
them and he goes d5 d6 h4 h5 hmm that's
close
one two three four five six it's
actually 10 moves that's really slow i
don't think i can trade trade or looks
that it feels that doesn't seem to be
right yeah can I take with a rock or not
rock TX rook takes Bishop chicks like
each form King b5 c3 King a 4 t-5 can a
3d 6 can be to h4 takes on c3 h5 pin to
age 6 C 3 boom might write just about
work well it's really important because
rupee eight then would be stronger
really stronger but if I'm kind of Miss
counting then I might just lose Rukia
droopy eyed bushy b8c three
c3 King b5 c3 King b5 d5 King a form d6
King a3h walking be to h5 king c 3 h 6
king b 28 7 knots that's not enough do I
have anything else I mean probably
should be eight is ok actually come on
let's do that I don't really want to
lose this race because I'm miscounting
stuff and this is this is just ok here
for me it's not not really any problem
so let's see what now exactly I want to
enter with the rook on the B fellow on
the eval
c3 this is the porn that I need to win
ultimately okay I'm starting with this
move tending would be eight
this one okay so look be aight i will
win that be a problem right i will win
that a pond and then he will keep get
his pants going as well I wonder maybe I
should try to win the sea pawn oh that's
weird actually that feels slow that
feels really slow okay I'm going here
this allows me to maybe take the a porn
but I can also check the sea pond I was
more expecting H form because that H
porn needs to run it really needs to
Bishop f5
or to take the apron h5 rook a 5g 45 h 6
g 6 and they're just about catch it just
about
h6 group c 6 h 7 rook h6 through pe7 and
then the a porn run Sam it really does
katelyn let's do it yeah those race
situation is always very very tricky you
can so easily screw up
maybe starting with g4s benim
I one day ever d2 d3 is an idea and
trying to stop the pawns just with the
bishop
h5 look okay if I think this is really
okay that should be ok ok five I
probably have to play I mean I have to
stop that thing age 60 page 5 is trivial
and now g5 that also threatens f5
aged 6 root g six age seven rook h6 Ruby
705 I don't think that will work ram
well now that that did wins so if this
fails it fails to something else
if I've come on that's right now who was
Rookie five an issue the self-penned
stuff now I can go back home well aged 6
root g6 there's no threat at the moment
King III is no threat at all i think i
can spend this move yes i can play that
maybe Kings Kings you three maybe
anyway I don't really have such don't
have so so much time let's let's get
this thing running I bet this time
stopping right this is this i can stop
h7 rook h6 rookie 7 a-3 I mean my pawn
is quick and I don't see how he stopped
said I don't understand really why this
would be working
rookie 783 then he has to go back then
really
no see no defense really maybe can
somehow somehow I don't know how exactly
if it somehow escaped to Luke and Bishop
versus rook but that would be the
absolute best scenario
I don't get this what is the point rogue
f7 maybe for look f6a a three-room f7
hmm
and I wonder if flicking n King these
sexist any in this us for a three rook
f7a to group takes f6 check group takes
f6 Queens man thanks was check on f6 it
can be put in a bit of a nuisance so
maybe King the sex skinny six rook f7
key six is very straightforward and I'm
come on that seems to be more precise
rook f7 king is six
yeah I put up a really good resistance
there which which sounds a little bit
like the game is already over which is
not the last door I still can screw up
quite mightily relieved and okay so III
now
yeah probably it's time for Luke g8 rook
age 7 and rook e8 catching the upon if
not o.o tix group g6 check what are you
doing to me very very cute oh Jesus
Christ
and a 2 takes this Queen squeegee one
check wind you uncheck king h4 Queen H
to check kingi for and I don't have
kinky sex mate because it can check the
bishop
can you believe this so look h5 org h1 I
come on Brooke h1 I mean I'm really
close to queening 5 don't want to
stumble into any more tricks than a tool
I don't I don't see it
GF a to f seven Queens
g6 is interesting g6 a 20 GM just I'm
just one move too quick
Oh tough business
is d5 any difference King these six
cakes at a to f7 let's check on a fade
that that is that is a difference give
this one this one form one through age
six and look f6e six wow what what game
is this that's really weird
wait a to wait wait wait a to know he
will take on edge f6 check a king and
look a 6 this is the problem Brooke a
six then I cannot promote because the
age pawn will promote
oh what a game Luke age seven look f6c
all of a sudden has had the healthy porn
structions this is totally crazy
and
and
time morning yeah i know but i do i
really don't see a groove I don't see
something really good
ok I have to play with this is not
regenerate but I didn't see an
alternative yeah exactly this is the
issue
no tricks or whatever I may be rock age
five and it's got King f4 it's not
really helping ok I have to play move
cannot I cannot think for ages fo gauge
three is one thing
king of forever we can go king of form
Jeff
King f4 is there some way to a check f3
this was my idea this is risky anyway
what I'm doing okay this one
rookie shrieking a form
yeah my time I really don't know this is
this is getting tricky i still want to
win but i feel like i should probably
look for drawers
ideas bishop c6 check rook a 16-7 which
is super risky try to win that see three
pawn and let the pawns that those prawns
run
King c5 I cannot go f5 at the moon hmm
should-should g4 maybe I how to
calculate let's go there first what's
down to 8 seconds
d5l sorry I'm f5 f5 root g5 this is this
is I'm stopping I think just about I of
course i can overlook stuff I don't have
much time but it's check actually better
check kingi five rupee 54 room checks f5
I don't know okay you know this is why i
think that increment chess or delay
chest is a bit bit more interesting
because you actually get to play this
interesting positions out to the end
it's not somebody just losing one time
it just continues with real chess which
is kind of more interesting than just
someone flagging rook a seven maybe okay
70 after that it's difficult to play for
a win i can take on click on at five
with the bishop and make it wrong
can probably have to probably have to
20 seconds sour stuff can always blunder
after one hour very very tense game
yeah one of them overlooking something
can you do something entirely different
yeah I like we'll get one or something
like Andrew get a 5 g one no it's not
not a really great I don't know look a 7
or something that would come to my mind
Bishop f5 checking f4 and probably
probably this will end in a draw check
not sure that this helped okay so Bishop
takes rook f4 which is six move that's
not doing much look at five to seven
check okay Ice King is very active you
played that ride with the check maybe I
should have come to d6 maybe
no way does this should be it all right
that must be a draw check
yeah I cannot win anymore have to be
content with the draw can you five or
something we draw yeah I will just take
check yeah very interesting game really
very interesting so I wants to go to c6
is there some kind of umbrella that
would be really really awful if I would
still lose this mmm King there
wow that is still kind of interesting
shoot King the 5c six umbrella King do
you live kinsey sicks check can you
believe this King be aight i don't know
i don't know what's most precise here no
then Dean 87 jacket just about and
what's down two to nothing Luke b7 check
I have 28 seconds again c3
I look be 3 or something and he
threatening made no II threatening no
he's not threatening made why would I
crazy game what is he doing now rook be
30
v5c see to probably have to
I don't believe that I'm losing this one
I do amazing really amazing wow wow wow
wow yeah it's a downside of those long
games as you sit there for more than one
hour and then you lose and it's very
simple really simple
black resigns what can you do Jan I was
very tricky with no time on the clock
yeah yeah here was I was down to nothing
it was down to nothing Jeff
and that is the drawer that I had no
time at absolutely no time just so shy
right this kind of tricks you know does
this you have to see ya still hard stuff
okay um amazing to lose that came really
let me let me go back there I really
want to want to check some things okay
well I takes it rookie 1c5 yeah probably
i should just play I mean I just
probably just suit this yam yeah and
can't win this in my sleep or something
I'm just the point up for nothing this
is what i should do we have just super
dry stuff not doing anything Carrie now
anyway check I mean this is objective
shine baby bella I don't know I really
don't know try the N Judah shatterproof
really rookie 2 is strong Butchie 823
again thats strong and takes and takes
Queen Queen form yeah that's good okay
aite group d we are up the one that was
was I was worried about that cost me a
lot tons of time poop q1 charity just
took this and now I'm better again check
and check and we just would win I mean
just like that i should just win the
game and this yeah we create I don't
think works I
f have my doubts there you go see three
and if I then started to run there that
that looks and looks wrong ok then I can
go back actually ok but in general this
just isn't it doesn't look right maybe I
can go back I cannot go hunting and then
then I'm just in trouble Bishop v8 is
also just good and this is just a
technical win if I'm if I'm playing this
right but I don't then losing was what's
very very awful I mean maybe at all but
losing is just it's just very bad ok I
grab this stuff you know and well I saw
at five but maybe we are will be 50 K a
5 this a and somewhere around here that
certainly aware now I mean I absolutely
don't believe this ok this is this is
maybe ok maybe I can do this yeah the
engine once once this check promotes the
judges and I saw this but I wasn't sure
if this wins I mean my king is wide open
and I only have one porn left I couldn't
evaluate that I mean it's very easy for
a while then you just place those kind
of desperate moves at hopes for the best
I couldn't I couldn't evaluate this if
I'm winning here or not this is why I
went king d 6 Luke f7 King e6 move g
seven and a three yeah d 5 he found all
those moves great look there and now g
sex again the best move yeah I didn't
see anything shatter than this
goes back yeah okay now i'm still trying
to win i don't know what yeah if it is
there some justification with the check
if i'm doing this with some
justification or not t5 yeah after this
I'm goes I really was their remarkable
bishop CA does draw according to the
engine but difficult geez 623 yeah this
is actually a mistake rook a7 was what's
good for wide yeah okay I I mean I had
no time whatsoever and I still wanted to
win but the no time says the biggest
issue Ruby for seem to be Jeff better
yeah I couldn't I couldn't figure that
out in that time if I should do this or
whatever this seems to be a clearer draw
okay even though this is also draw which
is 3d six I have to do this check it
goes there kinky seven kini five yeah
okay this is the draw I just wonder is
this may be an easier way to draw just
stopping the king check check and the
engine sets etc but ok that's it's not
really easier check yeah this is losing
I I saw the umbrella the second i plated
and it really was a second something
like that no umbrella is looking up to
see six and he's hiding behind the pawn
yeah I
but as this is also loses I have to go
to the aid check yeah it all comes down
comes down to d7 loop takes to sell this
is what you need to see check if this is
not there I mean okay this this is also
draw but now okay if you give me a
minute i'm doing this but check check
oops yeah it's just it's just lost yeah
that's really bad also you have to keep
in mind that i'm basically strategically
winning in this position already chat
with the center the bishop pair it just
over actually a 94 that was really a
very good practical decision and maybe a
know maybe just something simple i mean
i'm also better after Bishop d7 for
heaven's sake but I mean you who does
not take that this is the right decision
group everyone what the engine is
actually giving is this move takes root
e8 and this is now attacked and then
takes on c3 for clear porn this is the
best line problem
and I probably should have done that
something some may be thinking a little
bit longer here but not how long did it
take for this I took a while now that I
didn't calculate with him I should have
really looked at this a little bit
deeper that the King only seven is still
very annoying to play I mean this this
is what I saw I didn't really so Bishop
f7 that much but I saw this and this is
also really just a pawn I mean this I
don't really understand what stock which
is just on 0.64 black it's just a poem
for absolutely nothing now okay maybe
white has some some kind of compensation
but it's never enough now maybe I should
have done that but okay I had more than
one chance to win later yeah a very good
game here by mr. P foucha or pusher okay
hope you enjoyed that a very long video
thanks for watching